تعاني المستشفيات في جميع أنحاء غزة من
نقص الإمدادات والوقود، كما تم
تحذير بعضها بضرورة الإخلاء لأنها
قد تكون أهدافًا الآن.
وتصر إسرائيل حتى الآن على أنها لم تستهدف مستشفى،
ولكن بموجب القانون الدولي، هل يمكن أن تستند
قوانين الحرب في معظمها إلى اتفاق
جنيف؟  الاتفاقيات التي وقعها كل من إسرائيل
والفلسطينيين، وبموجب
هذه الاتفاقيات، تتمتع المستشفيات
بحماية خاصة، لذا بموجب المادة 18، ​​تنص على
أن المستشفيات المدنية لا يجوز بأي
حال من الأحوال أن تكون هدفًا للهجوم.
والآن يحتمي آلاف الأشخاص حاليًا
داخل مستشفيات غزة
بالإضافة إلى  المرضى والجرحى
لكن إسرائيل تقول إن المستشفيات
تستخدم لإيواء مقاتلي حماس، وفي الواقع
تعتقد أن مركز القيادة والسيطرة التابع لحماس
يقع تحت
أكبر مستشفى في غزة، ألفا، الآن
ينفي المستشفى ذلك، ولكن هنا جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي عندما يتم
استخدام المرافق الطبية للإرهاب
للأغراض التي قد تؤدي إلى فقدان
الحماية من الهجوم وفقًا
للقانون الدولي وهذا صحيح من
الناحية النظرية، تنص المادة 19 من الاتفاقية على
أن الحماية التي
يحق للمستشفيات المدنية التمتع بها لا تتوقف
إلا إذا تم استخدامها لارتكاب أعمال
ضارة بالعدو.  ويمضي ليقول
إن الحماية لا يجوز أن تتوقف إلا بعد
تقديم التحذير الواجب. ويقول نومي لويل، وهو
خبير في هذا الموضوع في جامعة
إسيكس، إن هذا يتطلب من إسرائيل
إرسال ما يعادل
رسالة التوقف والكف التي يتعين عليهم تحذيرها
للمستشفى  حان الوقت للامتثال لهذا
التحذير أو الإخلاء فعليًا. الآن،
أسقطت إسرائيل منشورات على شمال
غزة تطلب من الناس المغادرة فورًا،
وتقول إنها تسمى
مستشفى ألود هنا عدة مرات تحذرهم
من الإخلاء بالفعل، ولا يوجد
دليل عام واضح على أن المستشفيات
يتم إخلاءها.  تستخدم لأغراض عسكرية ولكن
حتى لو كانت تقول أنه لا يزال
يتعين عليك النظر في مجموعة من العوامل
بما في ذلك
التناسب الذي ليس دائمًا
واضحًا، كما لو كنت
أسألك ما هو مستوى
صوت صوتي الأعلى أو
السقف الصحيح لأننا  بمقارنة
الأشياء التي يتم قياسها
بوحدات مختلفة تمامًا، لا يمكنك القول أن عدد x
من الأسلحة يساوي عدد X من
حياة المدنيين، لا في نفس الوقت، هناك
أشياء متناسبة بشكل واضح
وأشياء غير
متناسبة بشكل واضح وهنا تكون هذه
القاعدة مفيدة  حسنًا، هذا هو المكان الذي
تعلم فيه أن هناك أشياء
قد يتفق عليها معظم الناس أه ولكن أي شيء في
المنتصف، أي شيء غير
متناسب للغاية أو
متناسب بشكل واضح، سيكون لديك
وجهات نظر مختلفة، لذا فإن ما هو
متناسب على وجه التحديد لم يتم توضيحه بوضوح
في الاتفاقية و  كما وجه المدعي العام الأعلى
في المحكمة الجنائية الدولية
تحذيرًا لكلا طرفي
الصراع بأنه يجب ألا يكون هناك شك في أن
كل صانع قرار، بدءًا من رئيس
الحكومة إلى المستشارين العسكريين
والمحامين الذين يتخذون
قرارات الاستهداف، يجب أن يكونوا على علم واضح
بأنهم سيفعلون ذلك.  مطلوب
تبرير أم كل ضربة ضد كل
هدف مدني سواء كان
منزلاً أو مدرسة أو
مستشفى الآن يقول إن تبرير كل
ضربة يتطلب تحليلاً ومعلومات
تثبت أن الهدف لم يعد
محمياً ولكن المشكلة لكريم
خان والمجرم الدولي  ومع ذلك، فإن
المحكمة هي أنه عندما تنظر إلى
الدول التي وقعت على
اختصاص المحكمة ستجد
الفلسطينيين في هذه القائمة ولكنك
لن تجد إسرائيل الآن، تعتقد المحكمة الجنائية الدولية أن
لديها اختصاصًا للتحقيق
فيما يحدث في غزة على الرغم من أن إسرائيل
قد تفعل ذلك.  لم تعترف أبدًا بهذه النتيجة، لذا فمن
الممكن تمامًا أن يتم الاستماع إلى قضية ما
إذا كان بإمكان إسرائيل استهداف
المستشفيات بشكل قانوني في الوقت الحالي فقط في
محكمة الرأي العام سكوت ملان سي
إن إن لندن